[Music]
as we kick off 2017 I thought my first
direct message of the year should offer
up at least one solid prediction for the
next 12 months while 2016 was near fake
outrage I suspect that this year will be
the year of misdirected anger before I
get into this misdirected anger I want
to take just a moment and share with you
guys how I ended 2016 by taking a
digital shutdown for about 10 days which
basically seemed like the perfect way to
end such a crazy year going off the grid
was truly the only way I could recharge
the batteries after the haywire 2016 we
had here at the Rubin report not only
did we take the Rubin report independent
creating a fully fan funded show back in
June but we started a production company
we built the studio then we moved into a
home we built another studio inside our
home and a whole bunch of other stuff
let's just say that if I never drive
another u-haul in my life and it'll be
too soon of course on top of it all this
commotion we had to actually put on the
show that we do every week and yeah
there was that whole American
presidential election thing add this all
up and toss in the constant beeping
vibrating and buzzing of this little
device and I think a little time off the
grid was well-deserved and probably
beyond needed I spent the last 10 days
with friends and family eating drinking
laughing arguing and most importantly
not staring into this black mirror a
couple times I went into my pocket to
reflexively look at Twitter when I had a
moment of nothingness but even the
desire for that lessened after a couple
days without it I felt calmer and more
present and actually slept better I also
ate food without taking pictures of it
and filtering it
I didn't tweet about Carrie Fisher's
death may the force be with her or wish
anyone a happy new year on Facebook
about a week into my digital hiatus I
had a friend over and I was telling him
about how I felt about being off the
grid
well I was really impressed by what I
was doing he looked at me Riley and said
so basically you're just living like
it's 1996 this off-the-cuff remark by my
friend really framed why an online
shutdown is so important to do now
again all I did for these last ten days
of the year was live life without the
constant access to video audio
information and interaction that were so
obsessed with these days well it seemed
like a huge thing for me to do I was
just living the exact same way we all
lived only twenty years ago and firmb
millennia before that it was only a
couple years ago when we were talking
about how the 24-hour news cycle was too
fast now it seems as if the news cycle
is virtually minute-to-minute and you
can be as engaged in it as the very
people who are making the news in the
first place all of this really does go a
long way in explaining why so much of
our political discourse seems so awful
now even compared to just four years ago
there's no thinking no nuance and no
honesty anymore we've traded those vital
tenants of a healthy society for
reaction generalization and spin at a
mainstream media pumping out fake news
and an online media that is fueled by
clickbait garbage and our ability to
find the truth in the noise is becoming
more difficult by the day this is the
catch-22 of any new technology with the
incredible advances we get like you
right now watching this in any part of
the world we also get parts that drag us
backwards like the misinformation and
time-wasting nonsense this all leads me
to where I want to go with the Rubin
report in 2017 one of the reasons that I
focus so much on the false cries of
racism and bigotry which now mostly come
from the left is not only because it's
stifles conversation and honest debate
but also because of what it leaves us
with without these two vital components
of a free society once you have removed
rational conversation and open debate
you aren't left with much more than
anger and violence since the election
I've been saying how much I had hoped
the left would take a look at its
tactics and do some introspection after
Trump's win unfortunately I haven't seen
much of this happen the left's lack of
self awareness coupled with the
righteous indignation that their
intellectual opponents are bigots can
only be a recipe for a disaster so let
me give you two possible ways that I
think things could shake out this year
say the Trump presidency is an absolute
disaster the economy crumbles we get
involved in some intractable war and he
makes terrible appointments to the
Supreme Court in this case virtually
everyone will be against him and
rightfully so
the media which obviously already hates
him will call him out the left which
also already hates him will continue to
do so and the right which is playing
along with him but still weary of him
right now we'll see that the ship is
sinking and that they have to find some
new blood even the dreaded all right
will fall into line if the country's
heading in the right direction
in short what should happen when a
president is doing a bad job
will happen now let's look at the flip
side of all that let's say that under
Trump the economy takes off we don't get
involved in any crazy military
adventures and Trump governs mainly from
the center the media is still gonna go
from outrage to outrage and tweet to
tweet the right will be thrilled with
him and the average person in the center
will be happy that there's a little more
money in their pocket the left however
will have an impossible dilemma on their
hands if the economy is good and we
aren't at war and most of trumps
policies are centrist how can you give
credit to someone who you've spent the
last two years calling Hitler
they'll have painted themselves into an
intellectual corner which can only lead
to misplaced anger but I suspect that
instead of looking at their own policies
and behaviors that led us there we know
that they'll only double down on those
very same tactics after all even if the
economy is great and the country is
going in the right direction how can you
give credit to a racist homophobic bigot
and even if you were to acknowledge that
the country was going in the right
direction then your own side would turn
those tactics onto you trust me I should
know I guess what nobody likes being
called gross and racist it's this
name-calling instead of honest reasoned
debate that got us here in the first
place all that said I have high hopes
for 2017 and I plan on putting those
hopes into action by making the Rubin
report more relevant and engaging than
ever before I think we can take the fake
outrage of last year and the misplaced
anger that's heading our way this year
to continue to build this new center
it'll mean talking to people we disagree
with and as ben shapiro says putting
facts / feelings
but I believe that it's a worthy cause
to fight for either that or we can just
forget the whole thing and join the
bigoted ear brigade choice is yours
[Music]
you